- Let's wrap up this hour
with one last super fun story.
This is what I'm liking.
See, y'all may remember a
couple I had here last year,
Kate and Dave, I met them back in 2019
after I saw a video from their wedding.
The groom and his friends
organized a whole flashmob
for the bride to my song, "My
Life Would Suck Without You".
It was amazing.
Not long after that.
I surprised them and
brought them up on stage
during one of my concerts.
Then this past October,
they told me that they were expecting
we're like a part of their family people.
And once again, I got to be a part
of a big moment with that.
So let's look back at that tape.
Dave, y'all have some,
some news to share, right?
- We do. We do.
So we are having a baby.
- Yay.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you. Thank you.
- That is so exciting.
- Thank you.
- I feel like I've been a
part of your relationship
from the beginning.
Oh, I feel like I'm part of it.
- Yeah.
- I was just like inserting myself, like,
but we've been there for a lot of moments,
even more exciting news y'all,
Kate and Dave had their baby last month.
Congratulations.
(audience applauding)
And we have them back
along with their new bundle of joy
making her TV debut.
So congratulations y'all.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Oh my God so wait, what's her name?
- So I originally wanted River,
but I figured it might be weird
because you're my best friend
and that's your daughter's name.
So...
(Kelly applauding)
My last name is Brewer,
so we wanted something
like BNB, super cute.
So we couldn't really decide
between Bailey and Brooklyn.
- Yes, we were talking about
it in the hospital room
and about 20 minutes later
anesthesiologist walks in,
a young girl and she...
"Hi, my name is Bailey.
I'm here to remove your epidural."
And so we kind of looked at each other
and that was about as fateful as it gets.
So...
- Oh my God.
- We actually ended up
taking down her phone number
and we're gonna send her
pictures of her namesake
every year on her birthday
and things like that.
So...
- Oh I love that.
So wait, one month and you
guys, how tired are you?
- We're pretty tired.
We're pretty tired, but she's worth it.
We're so proud of her.
We're happy watching her grow.
She keeps us on our toes,
but we're having fun.
- Yeah, I mean she definitely
sleeps really good.
Thank God.
And she likes music.
So there's even more
Kelly Clarkson playing.
But I also just love seeing Dave as a dad.
It's super corny, but he's so good
and the way he talks to her
and it just, it melts my
heart makes it explode.
- Oh my gosh. That's so magical.
I love y'all so much.
I'm so glad we're in this
relationship together.
(all laughing)
- I know.
- Well, congratulations again.
Oh my God. I just wish I could smell her.
She's looks like she smells so cute.
I'm liking your posts right now, right?
(audience applauding)
- [Both] Thank you so much.
- Oh my God. That post.
All right and that's not all our season,
long partner Pilot Pen makers of Frixion,
they Go-To Erasable Pen
of The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you
and you definitely
created something ma'am.
So they're giving you a thousand
dollars just to help out.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you guys.
- Thank you.
- You guys have given us
so much, you're amazing.
- Well, you're family at this point.
So we're all in this together.
(all laughing)